welcome back to the Jim Joey podcast
welcome back to our TV show we're on TV
this week first ever we're not uploading
YouTube were uploading the cable find us
on your local channels I don't think
that's how that works
I have bought us a spot Oh 30 seconds
cost me 10 grand Wow is that it's only
airing in Arizona good luck finding all
of that was alive episode is brought to
you by farmers dog guy start feeding
your dog food that they will love enjoy
and also thrive because of farmers dog
is food specifically made for your dog
oh okay like delicious food human great
food in fact basically the process is
really simple but they fit you and your
pet out with food that's perfect for
them and you can get free shipping 50%
off your first two week trial of fresh
healthy food at the farmer's dog calm
slash Jenna Julian or hit the link below
the skin is also a sponsor today guys an
amazing service completely free news is
really hard they make it easy go to the
skin that's th es ki mmm two M's com /n
and Julianne and to your email subscribe
easy-peasy
you're also entered to win a gift card
super nice deal and post me it's
something we use literally every day to
order food to order food and also
sometimes to order food it's a really
great app and right now go to post mates
in the App Store download it use code
Jen and Julia you get $100 off free
delivery credit free for seven days
check out the information in the
description as well Kermit don't be
wandering okay alright crime yeah
everybody just barked at the eggy's
because she's sitting at her bed in the
corner we were working with some high
value treats to get up the stairs just
now so she smells like treats so the
eggies walked over there and punny was
like get out she was like leave me alone
ok I've already humored my owners enough
to come up and do this whatever podcast
thing this is I'll sit Kermit don't go
over there you leave her alone
put the rat in it spin its hole welcome
to the first minute of the Jenna and
Julian podcast where we wrangle our dogs
every week you guys you need to learn to
listen like on set okay I'm the director
okay quiet on set in your bed marble
always listens well I don't think he's
doing much listening I think I think you
just like sitting there you know the
term ignorance is bliss
are you trying to describe I think four
marbles it's unawareness dis bliss lack
of awareness is bliss guess what's
happening on Wednesday
mr. marbles has a birthday it's his 11th
birthday damn what did my mom say
yesterday she said marbles is almost as
old as my celiac diagnosis that's what I
said that's what you say yeah cuz you
were like I got diagnosed 12 years ago
now and I was like oh yeah I know that's
funny mama you're funny guy do you find
it funny yeah yeah I'm just really he's
the curious one yeah she didn't hold
back she just was like great in his face
he's got out of here he's like should be
scared of that but he's not yeah like if
she'll bark at him so you know he's just
like he doesn't care you walked
underneath bunny like a bridge yesterday
hmm and cried and cried under her well
cuz if you're paying attention to bunny
if he stands under her then you'll hear
his crying for sure what a weird guy
he's like you know he's like that little
shrimpy guy he's oh my god oh no no no
no she just turned around in like eight
circles yeah dogs be like I don't know
what's that what's that about dogs
walking around circles boy lay down am i
right airplane food back more next week
come on watch my show
well first of all I want to wish a
special happy happy vacation to the
Debbie Machine she worked so hard all
the time makes our lives so much easier
and as a wonderful mother to you Italy
she's in Italy and she machinists email
it was really cute it was like such a
cute update like a family update email
where they tagged all the families on
the honey on the email changing you see
all the email addresses and she's eating
lots of good food and doing lots of
walking and enjoying herself she's in
her happy place
she's so yeah okay so here's the thing
we I've been really enjoying just like
kind of chatting on the podcast it's
seeing where the conversations go and I
think we're getting kind of better at
that but something has happened
I know do it it needs to be addressed I
know well it happened live last night
and live last night on Twitch
thanks to website called twitch.tv our
viewers / Jun and Julian do you remember
who it was I think his name I think it
started with daddy's I think it's
daddy's I wanna say like hmm we can
watch the vaad but I gotta watch a lot
thank you shouts out to my dude who made
me aware of this absolute absolute
travesty that's been happening to me
it's been afflicting me in my life for
the last 25 no I don't think that that's
I think that's I think I think
affliction is the right term for it
mhmmm I'm not sure I'm not sure I need I
need to get a nice little sip of
Gatorade and that's an unnecessary
prerequisite to whatever story your
bunch it out get ready everyone you know
where your pitchforks are just have them
at a very easy place to grab it's just
you my guy okay got our pitchforks all
right here we go
I actually wrote a letter well what I do
do I explain the situation first and
then I explain the situation so I have
been making cooking videos for last few
months and I've really enjoyed them one
thing that I needed to improve in my
cooking videos is the fact that I had
turn around to use the stove and then
turn back around and face the camera or
I would and or I would have to take my
second camera angle and completely
readjust it to look at the stove instead
of the countertop it was just a lot of
extra work and I didn't feel like it was
a fun cooking experience when I'm not
looking at camera and cooking I'm doing
one or the other so I thought hey I
watched benjin with Babbage he has the
induction cooktop let's get that thing
mm-hmm which one should I get
obviously the one he has right on his
website he has a really graceful list of
you know his affiliate links for all the
gear he uses camera cookware everything
sounds like I bought the stand mixer and
I bought the induction cooktop I was
like great now I'm beaming with babish
now I'm him that's it all it takes ah if
you want to be him to all you do that I
don't know so I received both in one
package took about four or five days it
was not Amazon Prime I will say the
induction cooktop was not Amazon Prime
the Cuisinart stand mixer was I think
regardless the cooktop wasn't I take it
out open it I'm like yes I got it yay
don't think anything of it make my first
video with the cooktop it works heats up
the pot fine I post a video I'm like
super excited that I didn't have to turn
around to use the stove fast forward
like 20 hours and I'm streaming last
night and I'm in chat just reading chat
talking and our boy comes flying in
galloping in on a horse into twitch chat
saying hey I watched your video and I
wanted to see if you had something
happen to you that happened to me after
I bought that cooktop because I'm
assuming you bought it off of babish
this list on his website and I'm like oh
my god I did I clicked on the link
bought it and now I have it he was like
okay well the one you probably bought
was the inducks pert 1800 watt cooktop
that was the one that was in the link
that was one that you purchase you click
the link takes you to the Amazon page of
the that product the inducks pert
cooktop it's $130 I clicked by done
ships to my house I'm using it he said
you
probably bought the one that I bought
which is the inducks bird it was off his
list but they sent me a Cosmo and I was
like wait a minute
Cosmo sounds familiar mine says Cosmo I
think and I wasn't sure but I was like I
thought I remembered saying Cosmo and of
course I'm not gonna think anything
other like you order something you don't
think to check that it's actually that
thing especially the picture yeah or the
the name of the model or whatever I've
also thought what you thought that maybe
it was just like a specific series
series in ducks the Ducks pert/cost yeah
or something yeah not to think that it
was an entirely different cooktop it was
a different cooktop and I only was made
aware of this because the student chat
was like this happened to me they
scammed me it's a actual it's a 70 I
think it's a 70 thought it was like
fifty seventy two dollar difference
Oh difference okay yeah I spend one
hundred thirty it was fifty eight $72
difference so I'm in chat like kinds of
scams so they they get you to buy a high
level cooktop and then they send you a
cheaper one but talking that we're
talking about Amazon here right like a
company worth billions and billions and
billions of dollars one that I use all
the time a service that I use all the
time I'm a proud Prime member I used
prime for everything I use Amazon fresh
I used Amazon pantry whatever all the
[ __ ] prime pantry that I'm just a all of
what I own is from Amazon well it's like
if you bought like a name-brand pasta
and then they sent you like CVS pasta
and you're like this you know it's still
pasta but I feel a little scams right
now if the name brand was seventy seven
dollars in the and the CVS was one
dollar yeah so it's just not right and
it shouldn't happen so it's not ready to
happen
I'm so I'm in chat and reading this I'm
like oh my god and I went and got my
cook cooktop knows yep it's Cosmo I
can't believe it and I look up the Cosmo
on it's $58 so I was like holy [ __ ]
this is crazy I had been [ __ ] scammed
dude I got had so the first thing I did
was ID and Andrew binging with babish I
was like hey just want you to know and
hopefully he sees it I don't know how
none of this is no not at all but I just
figured I would try to make him aware
like hey dude you know of to pee now we
know of two people me and my boy in chat
but I did you know I did look at the in
Duxbury reviews I was hoping to find one
that says I got the Cosmo what the [ __ ]
couldn't find a review that said that
all I saw was like I got this because of
babish I cuz you know so a lot of people
have gotten it so good good on them like
that's awesome first thing I did was DM
him
hopefully he sees it we'll see then I
slept on it and I was like you know this
is sad I'm kind of a upset this has
really taking me for a ride oh it's
consumed my life so I woke up this
morning and I wrote a letter it's a
short but strongly worded letter and I
wanted to read it to you guys on the
podcast mmm try and control yourself
Jolie okay to whom it may concern dear
Amazon I'm writing you today not because
I have a love for you which I do but
rather for another reason one that is
rather disappointing and has thrown my
life upside down for the last 24 hours
okay you know what I like cooking I
really enjoy making new foods and
putting my own spin on recipes I would
even refer to myself as somewhat of a
chef chef Julian is my stage name I
recently decided to spend some money on
a good intelligent induction cooker so I
can look my audience in the eye while I
cook the food I ordered the inducks bird
1800 watt portable cooktop I was
referred to this product via an amazing
YouTube it goes by bitching with babish
he has a list of affiliate links of the
products he uses on his website
I clicked by now and waited patiently it
wasn't until it arrived that the
nightmare would begin speak for yourself
not a nightmare damn about a $70 a
nightmare it works fine yeah you just
gotta but who knows how long it'll work
for or if it'll even explode it so
explode at some point I was streaming
live I am a camp boy and one of my
viewers made me aware of the fact that
he had recently ordered the same exact
cooktop off of the same website there
was only one problem
he received an entirely different item
dun dun dun
I wrote that
one that said instead of saying in
Duxbury across the middle of the cook
surface it says Cosmo when I read his
comment I was first immediately
intrigued because I remembered seeing
Cosmo on mine as well
upon first seeing it I don't think much
of Cosmo I thought it might be a series
of the product but when this gentleman
brought it up in my chat room I knew he
was on to something it turns out that
this product HTTP colon slash slash W W
amazon.com /gp slash product slash b o1
MTL x85 a slash rdf
p PX underscore yo underscore dt
underscore beat underscore ASI n
underscore title underscore o 0 v
underscore s 0 0 question mark i equal
sign capital utf-8 in ampersand PSC
equals 1 upon being purchased is being
swapped out for a product $72 and 16
cents cheaper HTTP colon slash slash w w
amazon.com slash cosmo slash induction
slash efficient slash counter top / cos
/y l IC 1 / TP / b up what i'm linking
people got it yeah I gathered that can I
finish
god I forgot where I was
you're ripping people off whether
intentionally or unintentionally it's
happening so I'm making you aware of
this please help me get my proper
cooktop but I paid for it ordered many
days ago also give me instructions on
how I should dispose of the knockoff
version you sent me love you talk sir
Julien thoughts I didn't send it yet
it's in my drafts you didn't send it at
all why not because I wanted to get the
podcast thoughts what do you guys think
no notes okay I'll send it it's very
thorough you have to be thorough last
time I went through a problem with
Amazon I had to be thorough I had to
have my ducks in a row remember that
that hold turns out I paid nothing for
that pin rack because they gave me all
my money back
cuz it's broken right it's broken right
for sure yeah totally mm-hmm broken
don't snarl at me
don't be a predator at me I did that to
kermit by the way the other day and he
lifts my teeth and I know you know the
podcast but cut you should send it
Julian okay I'll send it literally right
now the guy that said that in chat that
it also happened to him said that Amazon
gave him like a refund or like a what do
you call that yeah they they made him
whole from the first purchase but then
he's back at square one he has a cooktop
that he doesn't want and he doesn't have
the cooktop that he wants who cares if
he was refunded that's why I'm like
annoyed like I don't want my money back
I just want the thing I ordered right
cuz if you give me my money back home
I'm gonna do is buy it again and then
hopefully maybe not get scammed this
time but I still might like send me the
right one and ensure that it's the right
one and then we'll talk those are my
pens okay I think that's reasonable you
could also give that one to your mom she
was really she really liked it some 1
inch I was like do a giveaway with the
knockoff one I was like what honestly
yeah hey guys you know this shitty
knockoff that I've been like like so
annoyed that I that's it
giveaway time but also like if it turns
out that it does explode or something
it's not my fault I'm giving it to you
thank you you said I wanted it probably
explodes I don't think it explodes
it's an induction cooktop if it's not in
ducks Burt it probably explodes that is
a wild claim that I don't think you can
back up I backed it up right now I'll
email your people my data and research I
think my only two senses about that
email that you worded to Amazon is that
your life has not been a nightmare Julie
huh just a living nightmare day and
night why to sense
I've way more to say than to sense
here's my 45 cents here's my thirty
three point three cents I own
third of this conversation now why to
sense T sense is such a small amount of
sense here my two cents figure of speech
I don't want to listen that's two cents
here am i twenty dollars okay what do
you have to say Wow congratulations
you've just described bribing people so
let me I'll just send it right now I
need to find the amazon customer service
email Amazon customer what are you doing
I'm looking up Amazon customer service
email how do i cocked account contact
Amazon by email 1 888 - no that's a
phone what you've already gone down this
road I might have them on speed dial
from last time I'll look it up I'm gonna
send it after the podcast and I'll keep
you guys posted maybe next podcast I can
read their response are you looking me
like that here's something else man I'm
honestly I like I've heard of that
happening obviously through other
websites and things when you buy stuff
and then they send you not at all really
what you ordered but like a cheap
version of it yeah but I guess I've
never really heard of that happening
from Amazon me neither it's for it's the
fact that it's from him though I've been
scammed before mm-hmm I got scammed out
of not a small amount of like dollars to
when I was trying to buy one of those
[ __ ] hoverboards back in the day I
tried I swear to God I tried to buy on
Alibaba yeah and then I just never come
ever came and yeah that that is happened
to me and I know that exists on a lot of
websites but when you buy something off
of those websites you kind of taking
that risk with Amazon you're like this
is safe right
I have ship I have ship so much [ __ ] to
my house on Amazon yeah and it's always
come the right way and then when it
hasn't it's been a mistake or something
and I don't think there's someone at
Amazon going hey I'm gonna switch this
one out and [ __ ] this guy over no it's
probably like a they group them together
and they're like it's sort of like a
nobody's looking over here they look
exactly the same
you know let's save let's just kind of
get rid of these ones and see if anyone
notices right who's gonna even get
blamed for that
I have no idea it's not like a small
Etsy store what would you buy something
it's like this package we fulfilled with
love by Jane and then our heart by Jane
no it's like it's a [ __ ] Amazon
warehouse you know I mean there's no I
doubt there's like a lot of
accountability going on mm-hmm otherwise
this [ __ ] wouldn't happen I'd be pissed
I am pissed I'm very pissed yeah are you
gonna be okay yeah hot you know so hot
I'm hot your life is such a nightmare
right now thank God I have this cold
Gatorade that I got from post mates
right now if you use Julian no Jenna
Julie you get $100 off delivery charge
for the first seven days on post mates
guys post mates is a really great
service if you've never been on the app
for whatever reason I think it's worth
just going on the app and looking around
because you never know what in your area
a exists B has food that you might want
that you didn't know is there or C
delivers right to your front door
that's what postmates says it's a really
great service and it's it's an optimized
app it's really nice you buy the food
you order off the menu buy the food and
then you see on the map where your where
your postmates is in the process are
they picking up the food are they
driving your house are they there
so it's something we use literally all
the time they're open every single day
24 hours a day
there's always something delivering it's
really great my favorite is when we
start ordering from a place on post
mates because they have food or they're
open or whatever and then you eat it and
you like it and then years go by and
suddenly you're driving by and you're
like oh yes that happens all the time
I get that sign never would have
imagined that it looks like that
literally I and I love that people
there's probably a lot of people who are
maybe restaurant purists who are like
you got to have the experience and go
there no I don't I'm good I'm good never
knowing where the restaurant is even in
fact the less I know the better I think
it's only true maybe if you live like in
a city for a lot of people it's not the
case you know exactly where that place
yes exactly so right now I go to post
mates app in the App Store download it
and use code generally for $100 off
delivery charge the first seven days
really worth it also guys if your dog
likes delicious food which I think they
probably do go to the farmer's daughter
it's a really incredible service we've
been using we literally feed our dogs
with food every single day
what screen about farmers are because
they personalize your dog's meal plan to
your doc their eating habits their size
their breed and their goal and target
weight so if you need to lose weight
gain weight for your dog they'll help
with all that you fill out a brief
questionnaire answer some questions and
soon enough they ship you a box of
packaged food that you've put bunch in
the freezer and you put a couple in the
fridge so they're defrosted and you feed
them out of the pouch it's super easy to
serve them they love it can't say enough
good things about farmers dog also
really great customer service they
recently helped us switch Kermit and
peaches calorie situation because we're
trying to have them both drop about a
pound because trying to hit that exact
goal wait for them but right now you can
check it out by going to the farmers
dog.com
slash Jenna Julianne to get 50% off your
first two weeks and shipping is free
really really awesome service would
highly recommend and also guys get your
news the right way with the skin go to
the scam th es ki mmm calm news is
summarized perfectly and concise so you
don't have to weed through the nonsense
they make it very easy and bite-sized
for you okay so you go to this Kim comm
/ Jenna Julianne sign up and click
subscribe just enter your email and
subscribe it's completely free that's it
and when you do that you're entered to
win a $250 Visa gift card you learn
about all the stuff going on in the
world the good the bad whatever it is
you need to know about it and thus Kim
makes it very very readily available and
easy to digest for you okay you don't
have to pay nonsense attention to
whatever's going on with new sites and
Twitter and paywalls and whatever just
go to this game it's so much easier
check out the link below to get started
with that Thank You sponsors dresses
coming you have to sit boy de nada de
nada of nothing that translates to of
nothing right mm-hmm cuz days of and not
as nothing say thank you amazing that's
yes no say thank you to me thank you of
nothing that's what i'ma say no not not
you're welcome of nothing Kermit
why is he crying all the time
he wants to sit up here but he can't in
the bed he's having a bad little Kermit
timer usually it's like right about an
hour and he gets up and then he does
this but it has not been an hour my guy
it's not time it's my Wyatt sermon time
my dude you need to lay down God my
family came over yesterday my brother my
mom and my grandma and he cried the
whole time you know he cried the entire
we were paying attention to money
because my mom and grandma had never met
money and it was really fun and just in
the background it was like just a static
soundtrack we were all like standing up
in the kitchen at one point and your
grandma was still sitting at the kitchen
table and she we just hear ago is this
alright and we turned around in cars
just standing on the table in front of
your grandma okay his nasty butt back in
his bed don't this is what encourages
this behavior he bites you and you hug
him so you're like good bite he cries
and walks around you hug him good good
crying good complaining peach not us
right anyways you got some trends for me
boy oh yeah so I thought I was actually
on Twitter and you guys are helping and
I thought yeah what do you said you
should go about talk about some of the
trends that you guys used to be in when
you were younger and I thought that was
really funny cuz we were both into
probably some pretty funny trends I'm
gonna find their name Ranger Shannon
yeah so worst trends that we were in
well do you have someone you want me to
start I'll start okay go ahead joking
like yeah you go ahead do you think no
you go ahead I'd say one of my favorite
ones it wasn't even that bad okay I wore
Sambas they're like soccer shoes it's
not bad I just really liked him I
remember everyone in school had that
boys and girls and if you had Sambas
they were looked a little like adidas
right they did look just like I do you
know
and they were just a sneaker but like
everybody just had then it was crazy but
I can't think of a ton of like
cross-gender cross age trends that like
everybody had you know mm-hmm but that
at my school was just one of them
everybody wanted Sambas and everybody
had them yeah my mommy got me a pair
after a while because that was like I
really really want them that's so so bad
a sneaker but all like seven and
eight-year-olds were like I need it
that's so funny
Jonathan I feel like like there was a
sneaker like that for me too but I can't
remember like I mean vans but that's not
a trend that's just like a popular shoe
brand the Sambas were like a very
specific like I don't even remember what
brand they were or whatever but they
were called Sambas it was just they were
black and then they had three stripes up
the side and they were made out of like
leather suede or something so everyone's
looked like [ __ ] because we lived in
Rochester so they would get covered in
snow and salt and wet and rain and all
the leather on the outside would get
disgusting but we all loved our Sambas
[ __ ] you yeah we loved damn that's hype
they still sell those you should get
another pair for old times sake no thank
you
okay where are you I wore pants that had
zippers at the knees oh hell yeah and
you could unzip the bottom leg of the
pant and then there were shorts but what
me would do would be unzip one leg and
think I'd be really cool so you had one
leg that was a short and one leg that
was a pant essentially it yes when you
zipped off the leg did where did you put
it in your pocket in your like cargo
pocket yeah where they go
cargos some of them were Wow actually
most of them were yeah you put it in the
cargo pocket that is cargo it goes in
the cargo pocket and then you walk
around looking dope er dope as [ __ ] and
don't that's the best [ __ ] and looking
better than everyone else because one
leg is business and one leg is also
business just longer
like the age group I want to say 11 9 to
11 mmm I was the coolest 9 to 11 were
you yeah yeah what what do you think of
my pit I used to do first of all most
like banana clips that we used to wear
Heron so you would put your hair in like
a low ponytail and then twist it and
then put it banana clip in so that the
top hair was just like hanging out to
the top of the side yeah was dope as
fogged up as [ __ ] but also tiny little
like 90s butterfly Clips so you take
like a little piece of hair and clip it
here and then clip it here and clip it
here and clip it here so you just have
like this little head like beautiful
color and the big like ariana grande
wears them now yes yes but we used to
wear those were they are they pretty
they're hip they were but like people
didn't wear it's like you know when a
trend comes back and they take all of
the ugly part out of it and only do like
the cute part
yeah that's ariana grande wearing those
clips because when we wore them they
were like metal and silver and not super
cute and we use them for like when you
put your hair up in a ponytail you could
take some bobby like all this hair that
falls out down here it wasn't like a
cute look you needed everything to be
like up and like slicked up but like
your hair has breakage back here so it
just falls out and then that's a mess
right so you could take some bobby pins
and try and finagle it but they wouldn't
stay but if you play like sports or
something and you wanted that hair out
of the way you would take one of those
clips and you put it back here like that
or like yeah you could clip off your
like side bangs like that but they
weren't like big and cute and I didn't
have any that were like colorful ones
really huh like they had like a metallic
sort of like pink or but they were metal
yeah and they weren't that cute huh I
mean kind of hurt interesting huh I'm
down to try some do you have any around
that I can put in maybe my hair's pretty
short now but three fun they were just
like a
really good alternative to a bobby pin
because a bobby pin would fall out
sometimes depending yeah and a banana
clip is like cool it's like no banana
clip is different than those little
clips I'm talking about two different
things
Oh or they were like a claw oh I know
that thing yes we used to wear those the
claw was like the big one that you would
put in the back to hold like your whole
hair yeah yeah but then the little
butterfly clips were the tiny yes this
is the visual representation of what
she's talking about for those who
haven't exactly but let me tell you boy
the worst of the worst is when you're
hanging out you either have butterfly
clips in or that little claw thing like
you know when you have long hair and
you're out in the world somewhere it's
[ __ ] hot your hairs out of your face
yeah my whole life you go to like redo
your ponytail or something as it's
falling out and your hair tie breaks and
now you're [ __ ] and you're like oh my
god what do I do now my hair is just my
absolute nightmare situation so the claw
situation was sort of like you know your
your plan for the day right that my hair
is in this it's it's got to be up here
you were so many times so you have like
they're cheap it's plastic yeah you know
and I was like lay down somewhere I put
my head down the cloth smashes and
breaks one of the legs is gone oh my god
now the spring breaks
yeah the whole thing [ __ ] comes apart
you screwed
good luck with your hair for the rest of
the day that sounds horrible
I remember the claw being like that
brown color you know well different
colors yeah but the most popular one was
like the brown like brown black brown
Burgundy whatever yeah yeah anyway I
didn't use those but I my sister did and
I've seen them my mom I was in those
okay I just thought it for what
LIVESTRONG bracelets huge trend when I
was little school that was a huge check
I was I don't know how old I was
oh the middle school it wasn't as
popular well it was just starting to
blow up and it was at the point where it
was sort of like fashion piece yeah I
was like high school yeah so it was
linked I was either sixth or seventh
grade but
regardless I was a little I was a little
baby
julen in middle school and so the
LIVESTRONG bracelets were super dope and
I'm I'm almost positive that I didn't
have one and so I went on eBay and it
probably was a knockoff honestly now
that I think about it but I bought one
off eBay and it was like probably like
20 bucks like a ridiculous price because
they were like cool great but like
wasn't the whole point of to support to
support yeah but the point is it was at
the stage where it was like a fashion
piece right so you had to get one anyway
you could so you wore a LIVESTRONG
bracelet at least in the middle school
world that I was living in my brain and
so I didn't have one and I thought it
would be so rad to have one right but it
gets more interesting I didn't just buy
one off eBay where I bought one off eBay
and I and I think somewhere between
ordering and off eBay I might have like
just decided to do it from the beginning
but I think at some point I was like
this girl that I really like doesn't
have a LIVESTRONG bracelet
yeah I know you better watch out
try say her name whatever her name was
Sophie and I was like she's really
pretty I wanted to give her this
LIVESTRONG bracelet maybe she'll like me
and we didn't like know each other we
maybe had a couple conversations you
know like oh like what time is it guys -
there was so much more oh my god yes so
I got a little storm bracelet I wake up
I'm like okay here I'm gonna [ __ ] do
it if I can do it I'm like sick to my
stomach because I'm nervous and it's
before school it's like a period going
into period 1 so there's like a little
gap because I had I had a period PE so
your voice isn't as be because wait why
does every embarrassing story that
involves a girl also involved PE because
P because P because PE was the source of
99% of my childhood trauma that is why
PE sucks no you loved it I loved it
later on anyway I am in my PE clothes
it's early the bells ringing I see
Sophie in the yard or like the you know
basketball court
so I like walk up to her and I'm like
hey wait how about so at this point you
had one bracelet for you and one for
almost positive I didn't have one so you
just bought one on eBay I'm almost
positive and decided that you just
wanted to give it to Sophie yes because
if I pass yourself well yeah because I
that's why I think I decided after
ordering it that I was gonna give it to
her because otherwise I would order -
right but I only ordered one and it's
not like I could just like order things
you know you or put an ebay order and
that's like your mom's gonna be mad at
you and that's it for a couple months
like right yeah you need her credit card
yeah that's something right yeah and
it's not like I can just like get a
package and I take my room she's seeing
all the mail that comes in not me I'm at
school so I walk comes around like hey I
got you a list arm bracelet and she's
like thanks I was like I I'll see you
later
and then that was it I was like [ __ ] I'm
such a stupid idiot like she doesn't
even care stupid [ __ ] bracelet she
does not care that I just did that
she's like okay where do I put this now
what trash can I put this in and I was
like and I remember thinking like oh
she's gonna like me now that I gave her
a bracelet but now I'm sure she's gonna
think you're interested yeah no it was
just like here you go and then I ran
away and now is that that was that was a
head game what so cute and sad and sweet
and pure and it's adorable so you never
nothing ever happened with you and
Sophie no I had a crush on her for
probably most of that I'm pretty sure
was sixth grade might have been seventh
but I think it was sixth grade I'm
pretty sure I had a crush on her for
most of the year even when she had like
a boyfriend
but dude middle school was [ __ ] rough
yeah
middle school was rough dude high school
it's chump change compared to middle
school yeah middle school is definitely
worse yeah yeah I'm sorry
LIVESTRONG oh my god
yeah that was bad do you do you any
other
well my favorite toys look when I was
younger than that like seven like a kid
I didn't do like a lot of Barbies and
stuff but I would watch a lot of like
lamb chop start like Nickelodeon and you
know all the the TV at the time they
would have just non-stop toy commercials
I mean it's not any different than it is
now but they were always you know the
same groups of toys and those like
jingles and everything became like super
famous and like ingrained in your head
like the there was like a my buddy which
is just a [ __ ] person golf buddy bye
buddy bye but and you're like it gets
[ __ ] stuck in your head yeah see it
so then you're like brainwashed into
wanting these things as a kid even
though I have no desire for a person
doll you know yeah the the toys that
really appealed to me were either like
something I could really play with or an
animal like I remember I had this like
it was a stick and it had wheels on the
bottom of it and you would push it like
a vacuum cleaner and there was just like
a shitty little half stuffed dog that
would just go like this because because
you're pushing it yeah I love that thing
yeah but um some of the more trendier
toys that I really enjoyed where a skip
it which I [ __ ] love you put the hook
around your ankle and then you yeah it's
just a circle that you put on your ankle
and then you just I'm like I'm wondering
now like cuz I've thought about it a lot
as an adult it's such an awkward motion
like when you start doing you know when
your hula hooping and it's all like
pretty fluid yeah I think skip it was
not like that at all well cuz it's like
you put it around one foot you're
essentially doing like it's like a
hopscotch in place no it's like doing
weight training on one leg all the time
because the weight is only relying on
one ankle and now that one's just yeah
so like think of you whatever this
outside like the outside of your glue
and like your adductor or whatever or
that's your abductor I don't know but
like that that leg is working and unless
you switch the legs which like who cares
you know I'm seven I'm gonna put it on
my right foot and jump with my left like
you're just sort of like doing this not
that it's particularly strenuous but
it's like
an exercise or play thing that only
works one side of your body yeah which
is kind of problematic in a way like
there's probably a kid that did so many
skip it but like their right leg was
[ __ ] bumping and their left one was
for sure you might have caused the
complete growth imbalance at that point
you're a developing kid but so it would
count how many times yeah because it had
a little digital thing on it yeah well
it wasn't digital it was just an analog
oh really
yeah mine was the original one was I
think they came out with more great ones
and it was plastic like a really thin
piece of plastic yeah
so I went through and it made a terrible
noise because I would do it like on the
asphalt lay on the driveway
yeah and it you it just sounded like
plastic being dragged across asphalt
like yeah it's super loud yeah and it
would get all like dinged up and nasty
and I had gone through several skip it's
because they would go flying off my leg
because the plastic yes so you're in
your driveway like it's like you're both
your legs are out and you're just sort
of like stepping side to side oh yes
that's sort of the motion yeah and then
it would just go [ __ ] flying into the
street because we broke it but I also
had one like now thinking back which is
really funny I was a gymnast I did a lot
of gymnastics and there is an event in
rhythmic gymnastics or they have
essentially a ribbon dancer which was
what I had it's a stick with a long
ribbon on it I've seen that and they do
that in gymnastics and it's [ __ ]
beautiful and it's you know whatever but
I just had went to wave around in the
backyard and I [ __ ] love that thing
and the commercials for it we're so
amazing they're like you can do it in a
circle and it's like oh oh it's so
pretty
[ __ ] God and well recently I've been
playing a lot of cat's cradle I've told
that story in the podcast before I
always played with string and you know
just had a lot of alone time as it came
out brother wouldn't [ __ ] play with
me hated me he was hanging out with his
cool boyfriend's and I was the one that
was upstairs in my room looking out the
window me like man I wish they would
[ __ ] play with me so I would go to
the garage get my [ __ ] ribbon dancer
go up into the woods and go
that's so cute that's neither go go do
my skip it in the driveway here a
horrible sound get a little bored
realize I'm alone go go poke my hamster
in his cage [ __ ] he's sleeping it's
daytime go to the garage get my ribbon
dancer walk into the would you as a kid
it's like it melts me but the the girl
that lived a few houses down for me that
I grew up with was like she was a little
weird like me too so we had each other
we were but she had ever been answered
too sometimes for sure and if she was
around but like yo Libby you want to
play [ __ ] ribbon and she's like yes
[ __ ] we spent an entire day one time
jumping off a picnic table with an
umbrella to see if we could fly it
didn't work but you hurt yourself
no yeah we were those kids that was also
around the same time that I bought I had
a book that this these aren't trends
accepted the toys I guess but we bought
or somebody had like a book of really
like really close up pictures of plants
and things like flowers and so my mom
got a just disposable like Kodak camera
and I was like man I love those pictures
like they really inspired me and I'm
little yeah so I went out back and I
started taking all these pictures of all
these like leaves and like you know
pretty stuff and then we got the film
developed and they're all [ __ ] blurry
because it's clearly with the macro lens
and I have no idea whatever you were
just like getting really close to them
like my morning pictures of nothing but
just like blurry close-up grass that's
so cute so we're trying to like take
close pictures but you know yeah but you
can't tell because you're honking
through the little viewfinder so yeah
yeah but how is how is a child supposed
to even know what a macro lens is and
why those pictures are not showing up
when you take it that close that's what
I thought I was just a book of somebody
really close to [ __ ] I was like a
[ __ ] bait this boy thinks you can
write a book about being close to [ __ ]
watch
I'm even closer it was terrible
well damn anyways I had to skip it in
the ribbon dance I really liked those
rows and I had Polly Pockets mm-hm
I didn't really like Barbies but I did
like Polly Pockets cuz I'm a Virgo and I
like little small things
mhm and it was really cute but now as an
adult I'm like that is a [ __ ]
horrible choking hazard things were like
this [ __ ] big and you would just and
it was stupid yeah my this wasn't a
train wreck collected cards and
collected sports cards and pokemon cards
oh hell yeah I still have a lot of my
sports cards actually which is a really
cool thing that I'm glad I still have
because I [ __ ] collected them I know
you do
I've always we've moved them to every
house we've ever lived in it's important
to pretty doubt they're in the sleeves
and everything I used to train him with
my friends every good of card shows I
used to wear one of those like puka
shell necklaces yeah but mine was a
little different but that was a thing
that was definitely trend for me puka
shells
they were dope if you had puka shells
you were [ __ ] sick I've just always
liked chokers yeah like that has never
changed I've always like worn a choker I
think there was a period like we're in
college obviously I couldn't be wearing
like jewelry all the time you get in
trouble cuz the softball well like that
period of time and like a little after
college when I was like I'm good I'm an
adult I didn't wear chokers and then I
was like nah more Joker yeah back to it
yeah yeah that's funny yeah I was gonna
say puka shells and then also frosted
tips I did that you did that
yeah my war was like orange tips cuz I
just did a bad job you did it yourself
no I think my mum my mom yeah I'm pretty
sure my mom did it I definitely didn't
go to a place oh no
so actually my mom might have done it
once but my aunt did it yeah he was a
hairdresser and we they lived out in
Boston so we would go visit them and
while I was out there like on Theresa
can you dye my hair and she would in her
kitchen and yeah I had like blonde hair
I had like orange blonde hair I had I
had an earring I did the left ear
pierced thing that which I always ask
you all the time just let me try and put
an earring in there you know people have
asked me to pierce my nose
which I feel like that's just such a
hassle and asking for it you don't have
to pierce you know so you could just get
one of those little fake magnet ones if
you wanted it for like a day you know
huh I would sooner try that then put a
hole through my nose yeah I have no
desire to have my nose pierced maybe
they're just because I think I think it
does look really cool on some people I
totally agree I really like it but it's
just like I think it would bother me too
much
yeah probably while Dems are trends I
don't know that was like kind of a funny
it took a turn I did not expect to
remember that story man like livestrong
of all [ __ ] things that a kid in
sixth grade would want to spend their
[ __ ] money on e-bay to buy something
right it's weird it's weird and it's
senseless it's like everything revolves
around what's cool and what's gonna make
you look cool yeah that's a struggle to
be so like not lame and that's that was
like all of middle school for me just
trying so [ __ ] hard not to be lame
well I remember yeah in middle school I
totally remember I LIVESTRONG bracelets
but that's also like I think like you
said in their height they were like a
little more expensive like 10 or 20
dollars
I remember them being like five or
something but like I think the whole
poll is that a lot of the proceeds are
going to cancer research and I guess in
hindsight now it seems kind of harmless
because I've totally read comments a few
people being like only kids that wear
gucci and supreme are cool in my school
and I'm like oh my god that sucks how
expensive whose parents get for that
it's much it's it's like way more
expensive to be a middle schooler these
days and be cool I know but it's also
like your I remember you know even with
like the Sambas right I think there were
like $40 or something but that's like
you know speakers hadn't really reached
that like peak where they are now where
it's like $100 so like get a good pair
of sneakers they were you know that was
sort of like a reasonable price range in
there like 40 50 $60 you know wasn't
insane but like for a child's purchase
when they're going to grow
of those shoes you know in a year or two
it's like it's an investment you know
and for a parent to like spend money
it's like that your mom loves you so
much and she wants you to fit in she
wants you to be happy and comfortable so
they like spend money on you to feel
that way you know but I would feel so
terrible trying to explain to my kid
like I want you to feel that way but
like Gucci is not what's gonna like
spending $800 on a pair of sandals like
it's not cuz I don't [ __ ] love you my
guy it's cuz that's ridiculously
expensive yeah you know yeah but it's
just hard when you're in that kid
mindset don't you lady do if my parents
loved me they would help me get this
right I know why wouldn't you just guess
I won't you just get me that's all I
want
I'm easy okay just buy me this and I'll
be a good kid yeah I'm like my niece who
asked for paper towels and orange she's
a jerk Christmas she's a literal gem
remember Nike SB no I can skateboard
what was that just a dream woke herself
up what's my PSP thank you skateboarding
it was the line of their shoes that
still exists I'm sure but in high school
I was like kind of obsessed with them
they had a bunch of different cool
colorways and most of them were like for
five hundred dollars so I would buy
knock-offs right cuz that's all I can
afford and there was one called the
Heineken I don't know why I remember
this but it was like it was the Heineken
color so it was green and red and it was
the version of the shoe and I bought the
knockoffs and I was like [ __ ] these are
dope and I wore him to school one day
and one of my friends on the baseball
team who was just like a downright troll
he I think probably heard me talking
about them to someone because I was like
hyped about him and that we had a Greek
theater in our school an outdoor Greek
theater we would oftentimes do strength
and conditioning in the Greek so we
would have like Tuesdays and Thursdays
we would meet at the Greek and do like
Sprint's up and down and [ __ ] stuff like
that so it was Greek day so we went over
to the Greek and
changed it in my baseball workout outfit
different shoes obviously and we do this
thing that day where we sprint up the
Greek and then bear-crawl down which is
like upper body hell because your
shoulders are just like bearing all your
weight the whole time and your shoes are
just getting like [ __ ] drags because
it's like it's cement yeah so we're
doing a couple I'm like exhaust
everyone's tired relax [ __ ] this and
then I look over at Logan and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is he wearing my shoes
while he does this and he was he wanted
to [ __ ] prank me by taking my new
shoes and scuffing them to all hell
doing it it was I was so pissed I was
like how [ __ ] dare you dude and he's
older than me so I couldn't really do
anything I was like but I was so pissed
I was like you're funny and like you do
[ __ ] that's a cross line and it's funny
but like why would you do that and I was
so mad and they were ruined
they ruined that's no no it's fine it's
just like one of those weird stories
I feel like buying things that were
knockoff online really wasn't a thing
for me or like on trend until I got a
college yeah and I realized that
everyone period I got those every girl
that I knew had fake Louie Vuitton
because that Holt that pretty big von
batch or whatever it was mostly like
Louie Vuitton I lived in Boston it
wasn't a thing where I grew up like once
I got to Boston I got to college
everybody had these like fake Louie
Vuitton wallets fake Lee Vuitton like
think of 90s Paris Hilton with that like
print and then the rainbow one came out
and everyone was losing their minds so
everybody had a fake one and I never
felt the desire to buy a fake one or I
was just like yeah Ashley I know you you
know like you do not own a $300 handbag
okay like we go to the grocery store we
live together we can afford to eat
cucumbers and buy one loaf of bread okay
do not pull your $4 out of you $300
Louboutin handbag along we're broke so
funny you pay the same rent as me I
literally see your wallet right now
there's nothing in it
yeah but she had yeah I even bought
knockoff Pokemon cards but it wasn't on
purpose I think I was trying to find
some rare cards and I bought him off a
website and they came and I was like the
back of him was not the right shade of
blue no but yeah knock offs be like
trends be like yeah you know it was a
big trend when I was in like middle in
high school too
also I don't know why but like all the
things that I really liked were like
toys or like things you can go outside
and play with do you remember devil 6
yes I do remember those so they were
like two sticks and then there was a
long one with tassels on either side and
you would just let go like this and toss
it up and there was always like one or
two kids at school that were like way
too [ __ ] good at it and then I would
be like all right dude on it I didn't
have any but I was like I want to try
because I liked that it looked really
cool and so I would do it and I would
[ __ ] smash my fingers like I would
get super hurt and then they'd be like
this is why I can't have devil sticks
but thank you for letting me do that
yeah yeah devil sticks I remember those
it's like a baton sort of thing right
it's literally three batons to six and
then one that you toss up in the middle
with the sticks yeah Peter what are you
doing she's like when I'm rolling around
the floor come here oh you got God well
I want to see what you guys remember
from the trends that you were part of as
a kid because I know we're gonna have
missed some and I know some of the ones
that pop up in comments are gonna be
like oh my god I can't believe dunkaroos
Bagel Bites toaster strudels fruit by
the foot fruit roll-up now I'm just
naming what is it TYT why toys yeah
beanie babies it turns out they weren't
gonna be worth something I saved a lot
of mine I like my mom gave a bunch of
them back to me and then I had them in
the house and Peach destroyed a lot of
them but what I used to do is I
to take like little earrings and I would
pierce all of their ears or their noses
with my earrings and that's where I
would keep my jewelry that's actually
dope is on my beanie baby it's so cool
yeah I never did that so well my mom
gave them back to me most of them had
ear and nose piercing so funny what an
efficient way to like that's a very good
thing thank you
yeah like this the little like worm won
the rainbow worms yeah you had like a
nice little no I remember the rainbow
worm yeah yeah wow those were fun I
really like them well them's the trends
I'm curious to see what we forgot or
what you guys had as part of your
childhood trends let us know we're like
relatively close in age but it's always
funny to hear like your parents alright
yeah aim wow must uh what's wrong with
you thank you guys for hanging out thank
you for listening and watching our
podcast happy 11th birthday mom happy
11th birthday marble it is now birthday
month we have four dog
Gemini birthday's coming up lord help us
Lord [ __ ] help us I'll be making some
birthday vlogs for the dogs this year so
don't worry we're not gonna miss those
and we'll see you on the next podcast
and on stream all week you guys be good
and have a wonderful thing
you